- All right, Guemmy, so
sometimes sites ask for,
like, a phone number
for security purposes,
and I'm always actually afraid
to give my phone number.
One, I just don't want
random people calling me
all the time.
But how do you think about that?
When is it valuable or
maybe not so valuable?
- Yeah, it's actually super important
that when a site asks you
for a security phone number
that you provide it.
I think most people would agree
that they wouldn't hesitate
to give their credit card
company their phone number,
because in the case of fraud,
you do want them to contact you
and to verify those
charges so that, you know,
you're not responsible
for them, et cetera.
In the same way, providing
your phone number
to these online companies
gives a way for the
companies to contact you
in case that there's issues.
In addition to that,
the phone number itself is
actually a security mechanism.
So, for example, a lot of
us on banking services,
we've tried to log in
and then the banking service
would send us an SMS code
sent to your mobile phone number,
and then you're able to enter that,
before you're even able to log in.
And what that does is it
actually prevents that fraud
from even happening.
And so instead of just the bank calls you
because there's fraud,
it's like, hey, let's prevent
the fraud in the first place.
- I have to say, that last
point is very important.
Like people think this is all theoretical.
I, on not every day, that
would really freak me out,
but you know, several
times in the past year,
I get a little code like, you know,
so and so was trying to
log in to your account
and there's a code.
I'm like, "Oh, no!"
Somehow, maybe someone broke in,
or they're creating a new,
I don't know what's going on,
but the fact that I take comfort
that they didn't get the code,
that I got the code and they
wouldn't be able to log in.
And that kind of goes into, you know,
is that what we're talking about
when we're talking about
two-factor authentication?
That you have to have, you
know, kind of two devices
that, you know, say a
hacker in a foreign country
or a bad actor might not have access to?
- Yes, absolutely.
You're right that because
that code was only sent
to your phone number,
it was not sent to that attacker.
And so they cannot get in.
They're stopped at that point.
And also, if people
don't like phone numbers,
there's lots of different
ways that you can do
two-factor authentication.
We can send prompts to your device.
There's these things called security keys,
some people might have heard of.
There's a big variety.